Earlier we had code like this, where
we say renton equals new MarkerOptions.
We passed it a latitude and a longitude
and we set the title as a string.
Now this code set the position and
title for the pin.
But we can customize this further
with another property which is
the .icon property.
Here's an example.
Now you can see I have the same
position I have the same title, but
I'm now using the .icon property, and
I'm setting that to
a BitmapDescriptorFactory.fromResource.
And as you may recall from
Android fundamentals,
when you use
a BitmapDescriptorFactory.fromResource,
you can then define
a resource as an R.drawable.
And I'm just using the basic
R.drawable.ic_launcher.
Which is the default icon that comes
with Android Studio projects, and
it's an icon of a little
android himself.
So just to keep things simple, I'm not
adding a new icon to this application.
I'm not adding a new
icon to this sample,
I'm just using one of
the ones that is built in.
You can, of course, add your own
graphics as drawable resources and
use them here, and
in fact I would recommend it.
Because using the little
Android icon is a pain,
as you'll see in a moment, isn't
the most user friendly way of doing it.